être fort pour être utile
telle est ma philosophie
je suis Kevin a ingénieur de métier les
sportif passionné de sport extrême
depuis 2007 je pratique le parcours
un sport urbain qui consiste à se
déplacer d'un point A à un point B en se
servant de son mobilier urbain de la
façon la plus esthétique et efficace
je suis aussi le leader du groupe on de
spot parcours qui réunit plus d'une
vingtaine d'athlètes de la discipline et
depuis plus de deux ans maintenant
nous éteignons les enseignes lumineuses
la nuit dans les rues de Paris
ce qui était à la base un jeu pour nous
c'est vite transformé en une réelle
aventure humaine porteuse d'un message
d'espoir
mais comment suis-je arrivé là
c'est ce que je vous propose de
découvrir ensemble
13 octobre 2022
à mon réveil je me souviens
avoir été inondé de messages de la part
de mes amis venant du monde entier et en
particulier de New York me disant que
j'ai fait la Une de New York Times avec
mes amis du groupe and the spot
en parlant de nous le célèbre journal
américain nous qualifie même de
super-héros alors ça si c'est pas la
classe
la vidéo associée et la plus vue de leur
compte Instagram avec 11 millions de
vues
l'article s'attache à décrire nos
actions nocturnes dans les rues de Paris
plus communément appelé lights off
light off en anglais lumière éteinte
ce sont des sessions nocturnes dans
lequel on va chercher à éteindre une à
une les enseignes lumineuses en allant
atteindre un interrupteur pompier situé
à l'extérieur de ses devantures en
hauteur qui ne servent uniquement à
allumer ou à éteindre ses enseignes si
bien que les commerçants le lendemain
peuvent la rallumer s'il le souhaite
or dans ce monde il y a peut-être plus
de mille façons de faire de l'écologie
et bien nous nous avons choisi le sport
parce que c'est ce que nous faisons de
mieux en tant qu'athlète du parcours
il faut savoir que les actions lights of
existe depuis bien plus longtemps 2012
au moins avec des militants écologistes
qui le faisaient avec leur perche et un
escabeau
sauf que nous n’étant pas militants on
s'est approprié le mouvement à notre
manière et on l'a fait avec nos
techniques d'agilité issues du parcours
qui rappelle fortement les mouvements de
super héros de bande dessinée comme le
dit si bien le New York Times
tout cela me rappelle que petit j'étais
fan de super-héros je voulais même
devenir l'un d'entre eux j'avais un
costume de Batman que je portais à
toutes les occasions
entre nous ce costume ne me va plus
aujourd'hui
ce que j'ai grandi croissance verticale
et horizontale que je ne contrôle pas
nécessairement
mais le plus important dans le fond
c'est l'état d'esprit
celui du super héros qui va chercher à
sauver la planète
c'est ça qui m'a dit et qui me fait
toujours autant rêver aujourd'hui
Antoine de Saint-Exupéry disait ainsi
fait de ta vie un rêve et de ton rêve
une réalité
alors certes je ne suis pas tout à fait
devenu Batman mais lui et moi partageons
pourtant un point commun
nous agissons de nuit
car en France la loi dit que
de 1h à 6h du matin les enseignes
lumineuses doivent être éteintes sous
peine d'une amende
sauf quand l'absence de réel contrôle la
loi n'est pas vraiment respectée
on n'a pas forcément à vocation de se
substituer aux autorités
notre action se veut avant tout
bienveillante réfléchit et guidé par le
bon sens
si bien que lorsque l'on partait ses
enseignes on fixe trois règles
on le fait pas quand ça dégrade la
vitrine on ne le fait pas quand ça
remplace l'éclairage public et on ne le
fait pas si ce sont des choses utiles à
savoir la police les hôpitaux etc
bref on ne dégrade rien et surtout on
fait très attention à nous
un tel point qu'on ne s'attendait pas à
recevoir autant de messages de soutien
de la part des gens qui nous suivent
tenez une nuit je me souviens d'un
passant qui en guise de remerciement
nous a glissé à l'oreille un petit pas
pour l'homme un grand pas pour la
planète quelle
âme de philosophe
une fois il y a même un policier qui en
guise de contrôle nous a demandé de
faire un salto arrière pour vérifier
qu'on était bien les anciennes et qu'on
ne faisait pas autre chose
comme quoi il y a pas de bonne ou de
mauvaise situation
mais le plus impressionnant dans tout ça
c'est le degré de médiatisation massive
autour de nos actions
en effet que ce soit le New York Times
CNN euro news ou encore brut combiné TF1
M6 France 3 des chaînes allemandes
espagnoles japonaises tout cela était
encore inconcevable il y a deux ans
on a apporté une touche moderne
artistique sportive et c'est ça qui est
intéressé les médias dans le fond
mais il faut savoir que les lights of ne
constituent en réalité qu'une infime
partie de notre entraînement mais que
c'est la partie la plus visible
aujourd'hui de l'iceberg parce que les
médias en parlent le plus
on déconseille cependant aux gens qui
n'ont pas notre entraînement de le faire
à notre façon parce que derrière le
résultat il y a 5 10 voire 15 années
d'entraînement au quotidien
on s'est approprié un problème dont la
solution ne venait pas a priori du sport
c'est un problème qui a occupé l'affaire
politique à travers la mise en place de
la loi les militants à travers leurs
actions écolo
sauf que n'étant ni l'un ni l'autre
notre ADN ça reste le sport si bien
qu'on a éteint plus de 60 enseignes en
une nuit c'est notre record
on atteint des interrupteurs à plus de 4
mètres de haut et pour couronner le tout
on fait des saltos partout
bref ce qui nous intéresse avant tout
c'est la performance physique et si on
peut joindre un geste derrière c'est
toujours ça de gagner
selon la NASA plus de 80% de la
population disent aux éclairages
artificiels
hors de voir toutes ces lumières
allumées la nuit ça en fait réagir plus
d'un
parce que dans un monde à ressource
limitée le meilleur moyen de ne pas
gaspiller c'est de ne pas consommer
et tout cela ne laisse pas indifférent
de par mon éducation parentale
depuis petit mes parents ont appris ont
appris à ne pas gaspiller que ce soit
l'eau le gaz l'électricité la nourriture
maman est styliste elle m'a donné le
côté artistique papa est ingénieur il
m'a donné le côté cartésien tous les
deux sont arrivés du Vietnam pour fuir
le régime communiste
sans aucune ressource il y a plus de 40
ans
ils connaissent donc la valeur des
choses et me l'ont transmise
telle a été mon premier déclic pour me
lancer dans l'aventure lights of depuis
une éducation familiale en passant par
un quotidien de sportif pour terminer
sur une action citoyenne
si on croit la devise paris ne s'est pas
faite en un jour
et bien moi j'ai envie de croire que
Paris pourrait s'éteindre le temps d'une
nuit
mais son réaliste
on n'a pas à vocation d'éteindre toute
la ville lumière
nos actions se veulent avant tout
symbolique
ce qui importe c'est le message qui est
que tout le monde peut avoir un impact
positif à son échelle en prenant les
bons gestes les bonnes pratiques pour
réduire son empreinte énergétique que ce
soit éteint la lumière en partant de
chez soi en sortant du bureau ou en
fermant son commerce
c'est peut-être là une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan mais mis de bout en bout c'est
ça qui va faire avancer les choses
on est né dans une génération qui a
l'habitude de voir ces lumières allumées
mais est-ce vraiment l'héritage que l'on
souhaite laisser à la génération future
quand on a commencé à éteindre ces
enseignes il y a plus de 2 ans c'était
comme un jeu pour nous
si bien qu'on ne savait pas objectiver
l'impact de nos actions
la seule chose que l'on savait c'est
qu'on repassant dans certaines rues plus
de la moitié des lumières qu'on avait
éteint de rester éteinte
c'est en faisant de recherche que on a
compris que éteindre les enseignes
lumineuses contribuent à réduire ce que
l'on appelle plus communément la
pollution lumineuse la pollution
lumineuse c'est la somme de tous les
éclairages artificiels vitrine bureau
éclairage public et privé
et dont les effets ont été pris en
compte bien plus tardivement que la
pollution de l'eau dans les années 60 ou
la pollution de l'air dans les années
pour faire simple éteindre les enseignes
lumineuses c'est finalement aborder un
infime partie d'un problème bien plus
vaste celui du développement durable
tiens d'ailleurs n'est-ce pas là le
propre de la science capable d'aborder
un problème complexe en le décomposant
en un ensemble de sous-systèmes simples
constituant des problèmes abordables à
l'échelle humaine
tout cela me rappelle qu'il y a un peu
plus d'un an et demi je terminais ma
thèse en océanographie dans laquelle
j'ai étudié comment les fonds marins
régulent le réchauffement climatique
c'est un sujet fort intéressant qui a
occupé de trois ans de ma vie
mais l'impact de ma thèse est loin
d'être immédiat
car j'ai étudiais des phénomènes dont
les répercussions sont sur des temps
longs de l'ordre de 10 à 1000 ans
aurait tant un homme d'action j'aime
avoir un impact immédiat et visible dans
ce que je fais
telle a été mon ultime déclic pour me
lancer dans l'aventure lights of
c'est en discutant avec les uns et les
autres que l'on a compris qu'on pouvait
réellement avoir un impact
si tout le monde y mettait du sien
en effet si toutes les enseignes
lumineuses étaient éteintes en France
cela permettrait une économie estimée à
interwater par an soit l'équivalent de
la consommation annuelle électrique de
370 000 ménages une économie estimée à
200 millions d'euros selon le ministère
de la transition écologique
tous ces chiffres ne tiennent pas compte
des effets de la pollution lumineuse sur
la santé humaine et la biodiversité
puisqu'en réalité ces éclairages
artificiels influent négativement sur la
qualité de notre sommeil et perturbe le
cycle migratoire de nombreuses espèces
bref si tout le monde a un combat ici
d'un nous nous avons choisi le nôtre
tant qu'on pourra se rendre utile on le
fera
joindre l'utile et l'agréable telle est
notre choix en tant qu'athlète du
parcours
finalement la plus belle des lumières
c'est peut-être celle qui nous guide et
qui nous anime elle est pas prête de
s'éteindre
pour conclure et pour répondre à la
question soulevée par ce Ted à savoir le
et sans moi
bien moi je vous répondrai que sans nous
le parcours n'aurait peut-être jamais
autant fait parler de ces lumières
inutiles mais que la solution ne viendra
clairement pas de nous tout seul mais
bel et bien de vous tous
parce que l'avenir a besoin de nous tous
aujourd'hui
puisse notre message raisonné et faire
avancer les choses
alors éteignez bien vos lumières sinon
on viendra le faire pour vous
[Applaudissements]